يقع ستك خفكا على نهر النيبرو في منطقه
خيسون اقيم عام 56 خلال الحقبه السوفياتيه
ويعتبر الاكبر من نوعه في اوكرانيا يبلغ
ارتفاعه قرابه 30 مترا وعرضه نحو ثلاثه
الاف270 مترا
يحتجز قرابه 18 مليار متر مكعب من المياه
في بحيره
بمساحه
2255 كيلو مترا مربعا وتمتد حتى
يغذي السد غالبيه مناطق جنوب اوكرانيا
وشبه جزيره القرم عبر سلسله من قنوات الري
تجاوره محطه كخوفكا الكهرومائيه التي تضرر
الجزء العلوي منها دون ان يتضرر خزان السد
وللسد وظيفه اكثر خطوره فعلى بعد قرابه
150 كم منه تقع محطه
النوويه التي تستخدم مياه البحيره لتبريد
وقود قلب المفاعلات فيها
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه سارعت
للتاكيد على عدم وجود اي خطر نووي اني
فيزا بوروجيا مؤكده ان خبراء الوكاله
الموجودين في الموقع يراقبون الوضع عن كثب
فما الذي جرى
صبيحه السادس من يونيو حزيران اعلنت كل من
موسكو ان السد قد تم استهدافه وان الضرر
اصاب اجزاء منه فوق سطح الماء نشرت موسكو
صورا للحظه الاستهداف متهمه القوات
الاوكرانيه بالضلوع في الاستهداف
وقالت موسكو ان ضربات اوكرانيه عده
استهدفت السد ودمرت صمامات بوابات السد
وتسببت في دفق مياه خارج عن السيطره
ووفقا لخدمات الطوارئ في المناطق الواقيعه
تحت السيطره الروسيه فان المياه ارتفعت
بمستويات تتراوح بين مترين واربعه امتار
واضافت ان قرابه اربع عشره بلده باتت
مهدده وادت الى تجريف الغام زرعتها القوات
الروسيه
بينما اتهمت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه روسيا
بالوقوف وراء التفجير بتلغيم السد من
الداخل وصفه اياه بالعمل الارهابي لاغراق
المنطقه واست خطر يتهدد قرابه 80 منطقه
سكنيه يقطنها اكثر من 22 الف شخص ماذا بعد
تفشير السبت
تتنازع موسكو وكييف السيطره على خيرسون
التي يقسمها نهر دنيفرو لشطرين تتمركز
القوات الروسيه جنوب النهر وهي مناطق
منخفضه لكنها تستهدف منها القوات
الاوكرانيه
المتمركزه شمال النهر تكتيكيا سيؤدي تفجير
السد الى تدفق المياه بشكل رئيسي نحو
الضفه اليسرى للنيكرو ويعيق بالتالي حركه
القوات الروسيه لكن اوكرانيا تصر على ان
روسيا هي منفذ الضربه لوقف الهجوم المضاد
الذي بدات هوكيا